with at-home learning and many of us
working from home our wi-fi is being put
to the test
but not to worry because tech expert
sarah evans is here to help
hey sarah how's it going hi good how are
you
fantastic so many of our providers have
data usage
allowances how can we prevent ourselves
from going over the limit
i'm really glad you asked about that
because over the past few months i had
to move my office home i have two
distance learners here
i really had to re-examine our family's
behavior so that we could be better
stewards meaning we stay within our data
allowances we were doing things we
didn't realize and we were starting to
go
over for example i tell my children
don't leave
the devices on your tv
videos music anything that's streaming
don't leave the room with it on just
like you tell them don't leave the
refrigerator door opener don't leave the
back door open it's the same
for data usage that's one of the biggest
culprits video can really eat up
that bandwidth is there a way to see how
much data we're actually using every day
or every week
yes and i'm kind of a nerd about this
which shouldn't surprise you i like to
know how much data we're using and it
keeps us all accountable
and so it's not just a magical number
and i don't get a surprise overage alert
you can actually use third-party router
firmware if you're a little more tech
savvy
locally if you're a cox customer i
always go to cox.com
data usage and check what's going on or
if you're a mac user you can go to that
mac
app store and download bandwidth plus
or you can use glass wire firewall for
android so you have all your bases
covered in there all right so what tips
do you have for families that can make
working
and learning from home easier all right
i'm going to give you my top five these
are the same things i tell my neighbors
number one shut off the streaming
devices if you're not uh using them or
in the room
reduce the resolution of home or outdoor
cameras if you're still in the house all
day you don't need
all that bandwidth being eaten up by
your outdoor
cameras download movies and tv shows
that your little ones or your big ones
watch over and over to the device so
they're not streaming every time they
watch them
do regular technology maintenance and
save those big updates
for night time when the usage is a bit
lower
and this is a crazy one but it's true if
your router is near a microwave
fish tank or mirror move it because your
signal could be impacted by those things
ah that's right fascinating stuff i got
to move my router away from my fish tank
thank you so much there we always
appreciate it have a great day
me too all right las vegas